if I was just give any advice to anyone
that's looking to build and starting
either Media or product first you got to
know your demographic that is lesson
number one because if you're not focused
on that value proposition from day one
and you start bringing the wrong people
in you're gonna go into a negative
either engagement or algorithmic spiral
because for us if we have an 18 to 45
U.S male demographic and we start
serving ads up to a 65 year old
Cambodian lady she's gonna bounce really
fast or she's not going to click through
whatever it is and all of these are
signals to the algorithm that she
doesn't care about the content and the
more people that don't care about the
content or the product the more of an
uphill battle it's going to be against
getting put into search and related and
that is another lesson that a lot of
people don't know it's like search
related discovery that is I would I
would argue most successful creators
that's going to be 50 to 70 percent of
their their impressions
all right guys bang bang I've got
Richard here with me uh uh Black Rifle
coffee is a [__] massive company yeah
your crew's wearing a hat literally
walking people got hats on everyone
loves the product uh it's a massive
business now publicly traded business uh
you guys went public at a multi-billion
dollar evaluation whole thing we'll talk
about Black Rifle coffee in a second but
you had a whole life before Black Rifle
coffee yeah how the hell do you go from
doing all these other things to actually
starting Black Rifle what were you doing
before yeah let's go down memory lane
um I moved out to Los Angeles uh early
2000s sorry yeah I know I was doing the
typical pursuing the entertainment
career out there and um for a period of
time you know I was homeless living in
my truck because Craigslist didn't exist
back then and it was really difficult to
find a place in a short period of time
because I flew out there relatively
quick and was looking at places to stay
and I was like I'll be out here in three
months they're like well we'll have it
rented in two days so I drove out there
with all my stuff and hopes and dreams
and started doing stand up went to
Groundlings did all the comedy stuff for
a while and I got really frustrated with
asking permission to vent creatively yep
and about 2006 YouTube came around I was
cast in a top 100 YouTube channel doing
sketch comedy and around the same time
the iPhone came out 2006 2007 and
started seeing the writing on the walls
and so I taught myself how to program
I was sleeping on a porch for a period
of time working all these different jobs
well it was it was walled up it was
walled up but it was you know cheap for
La it was a 400 a month porch that's not
bad yeah but uh it was great I was
bartending downtown I even had this uh
degenerate Gambler uh GC who would come
in all the time and I was really good at
picking college football okay I know
this is really really random but I legit
worked probably eight jobs at one time
okay and what are you doing in L.A just
try to be a Canadian yeah I was just
trying to do the entertainment thing all
right if you're not funny it that's true
and I I'm not even close I am I'm the
worst I mean I remember getting my first
laugh on stage I was like what is this
all right so you're doing the eight jobs
what do you end up doing yeah so uh I
teach myself how to program you know the
iPhone comes out and I start creating
mobile apps okay and because we were
doing the YouTube thing at that time
YouTube was native to iOS so you
couldn't run ads on it it was like the
calculator app and I was like well you
know this sucks I mean we're getting a
lot of views on these videos and
everything so I started creating YouTube
apps so this was about four years before
YouTube even had an app in the app store
and I was linking AdSense to content
creator so that they can monetize it and
about that time the partner program came
out so we could see the writing on the
walls that there was going to be
something a monetization mechanism
Downstream but that was kind of like my
claim to Fame having been so early on
and that led to a great relationship
with alphabet with Google and YouTube I
came in and helped consult with the
product team on various different things
like what is now Creator studio and a
lot of different analytics like we went
over hot spots and some other things to
help kind of growth hack your channel
and all that fun stuff and
um yeah so I didn't want to break up the
band and the thing that I was doing
there on the comedy channel so I went
hard in the paint in a different
demographic so I sat down I was like as
a branding exercise what could I do for
a specific demographic I wanted to shift
from that 13 to 24 female predominantly
to a 18 to 45 male do an action
adventure Firearms explosives skydiving
all this fun stuff and because my
relationships with the studios uh come
in I would consult for them on Creative
Marketing strategies be it 20th Century
Fox Paramount Universal so on a lot of
the game developers too like Ubisoft and
I would help them figure out their Roi
because at that time hindsight's 2020 a
lot of the best practices that we have
like just even ads in general all that
was discretionary budgets back in the
day nobody really knew what they were
getting from it you know they looked at
TV print billboard all that stuff is
more effective than what digital was but
for me I could see clearly through our
demographic or key demographics on all
the different channels and social
platforms that there was something
Brewing there there was a more intimate
relationship being built than that of
traditional media and so
from there the studios and ad agencies
would be like hey do you want to help
promote this product launch and if it
fit with my demographic I would do it so
for relativity was a good example I
learned how to skydive and I did a Halo
jump breaching with C4 I went to Aero
environment we
broke down the rq11 Raven the Puma the
WASP all these drones and everything
that were Incorporated in the movie and
for me it was easy because I had this
never-ending supply of movies and video
games coming out I put my own kind of
creative spin on it with slow motion
footage and and everything else and
ultimately I got to where I'm at now
with just short of three million
subscribers on that and you know a few
billion views off of that and about 2015
a little earlier than that Verizon
wanted to launch this big go90
initiative I think it was a
multi-billion dollar initiative that
they did and they were like one of the
largest procurers of media at that time
I mean they were buying everything
television shows and series we launched
a digital media daily editorial news
brand for the Heartland Millennial male
as a mouthful but it was just like we we
need news for that kind of 18 to 35 male
and with a slight conservative
perspective on it now I joke I tell
people like I'm libertarian short of
Anarchy but they wanted to they wanted
to go a little bit more conservative so
um that's the route we went but
it was one of the fastest growing
digital media Brands they ever invested
in I think we got a million subscribers
the first year everything all organic
because we were kind of the bastard
child because we were that conservative
brand in that massively blue I guess uh
portfolio
But ultimately
um you know I stepped away from it in
2017 because the success of Black Rifle
coffee
um what's the story there with Black
Rifle yeah so how does that get started
yeah so
so of my partners Jared Matt and Evan
everyone kind of had irons and other
fires those guys were focused on
transitioning from their time in
military service into civilian life and
they had modes to do so with these
different businesses
Jared and Matt had Article 15 clothing I
think they have a whiskey company and
some other stuff too and Evan was doing
twist rate which was a tactical
instructional Media company and then
there was ready man which was
um American kind of preparedness
strategy tutorials and stuff like that
and Evan and Matt JT wanted to do a
sample coffee Rose profile for Article
15 clothing and it sold out super super
fast I think it was a thousand bags or
something like that I'm going to be off
on the numbers but it sold out extremely
fast to the point where they were like
hey maybe there's something here and so
and what like when you're selling those
bags how much are you selling them for
usually
um now we're selling for about 16 bucks
okay yeah and how much does it cost the
business to actually get the bag make
the bag it varies and so that was that
was some of the challenges early on
because we really didn't know what
volume was going to be and that is for a
cpg company
extremely hard not knowing how and when
to turn those dials our first year I did
350 million views on my content
promoting the brand and that's through
Verizon so in my contract with Verizon I
had that I could promote my own Brands
which is great because it was on their
dime
and they were they were happy with it
because I brought all my friends all of
my talent into that Network to help this
symbiotic relationship grow which
ultimately led to them having the
fastest growing digital brand they ever
invested in
um so for us 350 million organic by me
alone Matt he had a killer Facebook page
he was doing these uh rap videos and
stuff like that they're really really
related to just everybody it was
hilarious stuff but the organic traffic
alone in our first year most people
would kill for I mean you break that
down in a CPM a startup most people
can't afford that and so for us it
became this Challenge and trying to
figure out really how to turn those
dials because you get a viral video and
you only have enough supply for 10 000
customers you're going to get a lot of
customer service inquiries a lot of
pissed off people that you know they're
really frustrated with not being able to
get their product because it's taken a
month or whatever so for us it became
this challenge and hats off to Evan he
the dude is just a phenomenal an
exceptional businessman he like we we
reinvested everything that the company
made back into Shoring up the supply
chain we you know we had to turn dials
with other Roasters whenever we did get
those viral hits or we get on say Fox
News or something like that
we'd have to lean on third parties to
help us scale our rows to be able to
meet the demand so we ultimately
reinvested into a roasting facility in
Nashville well Manchester Tennessee
and that allowed us to be able to turn
the doll ourself which increased our
profit margins which today you see a lot
of other coffee companies out there most
of them are white label they're they're
going to the same people we did back in
the day so their profit margins aren't
going to be anywhere near what ours are
and again hats off to Evan for really
like focusing on that and the the guy's
just been exceptional at what he does
and and hiring fast firing fast third
parties and and whatnot and being able
to scale the business so when you think
about that business how much of it was
dependent early on with the organic
views from just kind of like the core
group versus today it's the same thing
right or have you guys gotten much
smarter because I see you guys have
podcasts you have tons of sponsorships
like there's a bunch of stuff now going
on where it almost to some degree feels
like I'm marketing company with a you
know a coffee product and that's almost
been the secret of the success is that
like a fair way to think about it
absolutely I mean you you can 110 say
we're a media company that sells a
product uh you know early on the
strategy like and this isn't no secret I
did this with Verizon I did it with us
so I established a foundation it starts
with inspiration and education videos
and then there's entertainment videos uh
or education uh information then
entertainment and then inspiration so
our foundation was education be it how
to make coffee in a Chemex how to fold a
Chemex Coffee filter you know those
things are intimidating to a lot of
people so we build this in this massive
library that when people come to us they
know where the subject matter expert on
this but they also get valuable
information on how to make their coffee
what's the best coffee what are our
coffees taste like and then when we
start hitting these entertaining viral
pieces of content they have this library
to go to but then we work the algorithm
because because now YouTube or whoever
is seeing that oh this video is
successful what about these other videos
so we're going to rank higher when
people are looking for coffee stuff just
based off of the affiliation between our
high performers and then we switch gears
into inspiration so we shift the mission
uh or we shift the content to our
mission statement which is as far as a
company's concerned we're helping
veterans transition from military
service like our Founders did into
civilian life but then for our
non-profit and the company in itself
giving back to veteran and first
responder communities and
so having done that without organic
content we wouldn't be who we are
without social media Black Rifle coffee
doesn't exist I will confidently say
that now early days if anyone said that
that was gonna you know be the thing
that all of us were you know chips in on
they'd be lying if they said that
because we just didn't know back then
it's just a series what's the what's the
saying where uh luck is the intersection
of opportunity and preparedness yeah and
that's exactly what it was like like
again hats off to my partners and
everyone because
it would everyone was so ready and
willing to take up the mission that I I
don't think that anybody else could have
pulled it off like that how important
was it that the product was coffee
versus anything else I think it was
extremely important because you look at
the saturation point of specific
products at the time Article 15 is a
great example where you had Matt and JT
two of my other partners they had a
t-shirt company
predominantly t-shirt they sold other
stuff but then
the market started to saturate you
started getting all the all these other
um veterans exit in their their military
service and then they started these
t-shirt companies it started to get a
little saturated and like okay well
what's my value proposition that
somebody what's unique to it and
everything for us coffee was unique I
mean say what you want about Starbucks
but Howard Schultz really he was the
Steve Jobs at Coffee he changed an
industry I mean he took sugar water and
made it an everyday thing like I think
their their
tagline is they're the third place so
there's work and there's home and
they're the third place
um and it's true I mean you see how it's
infiltrated pretty much
pop culture as it is
um
and so now where was I going on that in
terms of the coffee itself though like
could you have done it with I don't know
[__] body oh oh yeah yeah sorry yeah
so so coffee was a unique it was a
unique good and that it really appealed
to the culture so that key demographic
of the 18 to 45 male specifically
military culture because everybody is
drinking caffeine to get energy drinks
or coffee and nobody else was doing that
right so that you had this you had this
which became in that 2016 era of trump
uh and the whole polarization and
politics it became you know Starbucks
started leaning harder left in that with
the immigration
um you know statements and and
everything else and so we became that
that alternative for the military
culture and and specifically like the
the conservatives
um and that was to our benefit because
there was nobody else in that sector and
does coffee like align really well with
the videos and and blowing things up and
like kind of like the hard charging
extraordinary life you know type content
is that's somebody who drinks a lot of
coffee I mean you could say that but I
I would argue that's just convenient
okay because
I've I've made the joke that
men want to be Matt women want to do him
it's it's just you it's hard not to like
the people in the company you hang out
with everyone like Jared is a social
butterfly like that guy he knows more
people than anybody else I know like
I'll I'll run into a random guy on the
street and bf I don't know Oklahoma I'm
like oh you know JT yeah it's like like
everybody knows these guys everybody
wants to be them or be around them and
hang out and I think that's just it was
a convenient thing that Evan was just
smart enough to really focus on
optimizing the business and scaling it
in a way as fast as possible and as
efficient as possible how'd you guys
fund it was it all self-funded it was
self-funded for the most part
um we brought investors in uh at a
couple points for various different
things The Roaster facilities
um but yeah we didn't we didn't really
bring in a lot of yeah and then uh the
whole idea of going public I think a lot
of people they started a coffee company
and they're like we're [__] around on
the internet we're gonna sell coffee oh
look it works okay that's cool oh wait
hold on it's like really working at what
point or like why go public yeah so
that's interesting because going into
covid we were positioned really well
because we were a d2c company primarily
and we didn't have the overhead that a
lot of cpg companies had getting caught
with their pants down when everything
was shut down
we were able to still roast still ship
and get to our consumers and if anything
they were they were drinking more at
home than going out and stopping at say
a Starbucks or Dutch Bros or Duncan or
wherever and that worked to our benefit
but as covid started easing up
restrictions in these different areas
our Focus was scaling out brick and
mortar or our outposts so that we could
position ourselves around these military
bases and larger markets strategically
to get to our customers in a day-to-day
kind of convenient way
and when you think about that experience
what is like the biggest surprise
through the whole thing
of building that business
whatever you just thought say that what
is that what what is that
what was that surprise yeah no so for me
again this goes back don't [__]
[__] me what is that okay so this
goes back to the libertarian thing I
like
I I fall under a lot of scrutiny because
a lot of three-letter organizations like
DOD and ATF uh I fall into their
oversight uh they like you or no yeah I
I don't know
um I'm I'm buttoned up Soup To Nuts I
dot every eye across every T but I just
don't want another one like the SEC in
my life where I come on the pop podcast
and I say something about revenue and I
was like oh [__] that's a
forward-looking statement it's like and
then I have to like like I'm not Elon
Musk I can't take like a 200 million
dollar fine or something like that so I
just don't like that
oversight like that's
I have too much oversight in my life I
like to be candid yeah and I like to be
as uh transparent as possible I don't
like worrying about what I say that's
fair yeah that's very fair all right and
now you're doing other things other than
just Black Rifle coffees yeah explain
that yeah so I feel fortunate in that
the way I look at life is I'm a subject
matter Enthusiast I've been really good
at the things that I do because I
approach it as a consumer or viewer this
is what I want and this is where I see
the industry going and for me I've seen
the riding on the wall with social with
um mobile where I see it again in
blockchain and there's an opportunity
here and unfortunately there's all these
people looking to extract value early
days and not necessarily provide value
to move the ball and I'll tell you what
I mean by that is like early days mobile
there were a lot of people who made
millions of dollars on the flashlight
app and I don't care about that I get it
get your bag secure it have fun do your
thing how much do you guys make on the
IPO hey guys what's going on I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation I
wanted to interrupt for a second to tell
you about an event that we're hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center it's called lyceum Miami and I've
gone and asked some of the most popular
guests from this show over the years to
come in person at the event it's gonna
to be awesome we have everyone from
Kathy Wood to Vivek Rama Swami Chris
Williamson Cody Sanchez and many many
others I also even have a couple of
surprises for each one of you if you
show up the best part about this event
is it is completely free to attend
that's right all general admission
tickets are free you simply need to go
to
lyceummiami.com
lyceummiami.com will get you free
tickets on March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center and if you're a big
baller and don't just want to get a free
ticket you can also get it VIP or an
Insider pass if you use the code pump 40
you'll get 40 off they get you all kinds
of cool things like the night before a
cocktail with the actual speakers and a
couple other perks go check it all out
at bycmiami.com and use code pump 40 if
you want to be a baller I can't wait to
see all of you there go ahead and click
on the link in the description and let's
get back into this conversation are you
allowed to say
um I don't know if cap tables are public
or not I assume so if it's like yeah
well when you go public yeah like how
much do you think like the core team
before or whatever made I don't know
I don't know I'm so reluctant to say
numbers
but so so having said that about the
flashlight app
so you know and I'll probably get two
billion yeah so like the four of you
yeah you did okay maybe yeah I assume so
yeah you'll have to talk to my
accountants but so uh
the App Store like Apple's gonna replace
that it's going to be native right to
iOS I'm looking five ten years out like
inventory control management Via Mobile
dot device which is what we were talking
about earlier with Best Buy most people
you know now hindsight's 2020 you have
the benefit of that you can say hey look
you know I can go to Best Buy and check
the inventory before I get there 15
years ago you couldn't and most people
weren't thinking about that then I was I
just didn't have the money to Pat in
that process or start building it for
people uh and so I see this this
opportunity and blockchain and the sins
of web 2 and
you know unfortunately what trying to
break this down for my viewers who might
be listening in on this you know the
early days of web 2 you know
unfortunately there wasn't a payment
mechanism built into the HTTP protocol
had there been we might not have taken
traditional media advertising like
overlays native and everything else and
applied it to web 2 like YouTube and
everything else the unfortunate
byproduct of that is you know we're
we're all about a quantity we want sheer
volume of Impressions because that's
what gets you ads that's what gets you
results so you have to tap on the nerve
you got a fight or flight response you
got to be controversial you got to be
angry you got to elicit uh an emotional
reaction from people but I think people
really just want value they don't want
to be wrecked emotionally and everything
so there's a lot of problems that can be
solved I think in in web 3 where
through incentive mechanisms
monetization mechanisms if we get it
right and in a permissionless way or
decentralized these are I know these are
a lot of buzzwords but they mean a lot
and the implications are are vast
because if you look at The Gatekeepers
the the apples the YouTubes like their
their Hardware to their software like
YouTube as an example
with the content that I would do on my
YouTube Channel full mag everything's
legal you will not find anyone more
buttoned up than me I have just about
every federal license and clearance that
you can think of I have permits I have
insurance I have instructor ratings
range safety officer all these different
things
and yet still my videos will get
demonetized or pulled and it's really
really frustrating for me because what
I'm doing is 100 legal it's just by
doing so well you don't have the right
to 100 distribution or reach like you
can still publish it well that's screwed
up because I just spent 15 years of my
life and not only that YouTube invested
in my channel I was I was part of
YouTube's next up where they spent I
think it was uh forty or seventy
thousand dollars investing in 25
channels it's like oh okay now you guys
changed the rules of the game but I'm
doing everything legally it's just
you're changing a social narrative or
you're changing the distribution which
is impacting a social narrative and it's
arguably going to make those kids grew
up in a world where Firearms may be
taboo and it's like whoa
I disagree with that I think in unless
it's unless it's illegal all that stuff
should be fair game like people should
have car a hard conversation about hard
topics it's you shouldn't try to control
that for people so I'm building a lot of
products right now you know I know
there's a lot of people out there like
oh we'll do the guns YouTube or we'll do
this YouTube it's like you're not going
to compete with the second largest
search engine you're not going to beat
them at their game there has to be a fun
a fundamental shift in in something like
a base layer that's built that people
can build on top of and then they can
have their own Discovery and again I go
back to the incentive mechanisms and a
monetization mechanisms those are the
key components but short term I'm
working on some security products
because I think that that's really
important a lot of people are getting
scammed a lot of people are getting
fished
um how bad do you think that problem is
I would say it is it is 99
of all attack uh stems from some form of
fishing yeah because most people they
say oh I got hacked like no dude you
clicked on a link here or did this like
no there are a few instances where
higher level organizations may have the
ability to access devices remotely Pion
attacks and stuff like that but
realistically speaking the bulk majority
of consumers are getting fished now
there may be some people there against
spearfished where they're being
specifically targeted but
um that's that's it so like I'm trying
to figure out ways to mitigate that and
and and reduce that risk when you look
kind of zoom out in the world what are
like the big things that you think are
important right now so obviously you
guys did Black Rifle coffee you're
focused some on the security stuff like
what else in the world interests you
right now
yeah it's a tough one because
I'm at this point in life where
I think you hit a point you probably did
uh when you had your first child uh it
it's like what does it all mean I know
this very it's like it's an existential
crisis moment or something along those
lines but it you know at the end of the
day if if we're just eating sleeping
living and then dying
at some point you've got to make the
world a better place like you've got to
put a positive impact so it starts with
your family then your community maybe
your state and then higher up I do think
people should
vote third party and get away from the
polarization and politics like
specifically on a local level like I
would like just play as active a role in
your community as possible I don't
generally talk about charitable stuff
but one of the things I think have
really like really really big impacts
um on the day-to-day like whenever I was
living in Los Angeles
um again you know it's hard not to get
emotional was like didn't you know it
didn't have a whole lot of money yeah
but I made sure I spent the time to give
back
so every Tuesday I go animal shelters
and walk talks because it would help
with their kennel anxiety and most of
the volunteers just go you could walk a
dog yeah so man this would like so the
LA system is like it's such a process it
took me almost a year to qualify because
you got to apply and then they approve
you because they don't want people just
coming and doing it for the holidays and
then leaving oh interesting basically
they want you to be a regular yeah and
so you have to go through this whole
process okay and then once you get
cleared and everything then you're good
to go which it was it was really
gratifying for me because again this is
early days of social media but I created
like the Facebook page for the North
Valley Animal Shelter which was this it
was one of the highest kill rate
shelters in the U.S but predominantly
most of their walkers were younger
female and so they couldn't most the
dogs coming in are either pit bulls or
Chihuahuas and those have the highest
euthanasia rate and so you know none of
the pit bulls would get walked because
they were just you know too big and so
it was one of those things that I could
I could do go there walk work with them
and everything and hopefully
um that made them more adoptable
um
relieve some of that kennel anxiety and
um helped a few out there along the
process but it people I think they uh
I think they think that a dollar here to
this organization is great but I think
your time is so much more valuable and
you can make
um much greater meaningful impact
directly in your community than worrying
about
too many things abroad if your whole
focus is things
outside of your community I think you're
missing an opportunity you really make a
positive impact I completely agree and I
also think that a lot of people because
of social media they focus on uh
International or even National level
issues but there's [__] going on in your
backyard yeah right for sure and
actually there's a lot of [__] going on
in your backyard yeah and um I always
ask people like when's the last time you
watched local news
never right like who watched local news
right yeah
um and so when you do that you start to
realize like again it's not all bad yes
there's car crashes there's you know
crime or whatever but also like there's
somebody literally within a you know
three mile radius of your of where you
are that needs help or could use a
helping hand or you know whatever
and if you just focus on that like
that's something you can actually impact
what's going on in another country
yeah maybe right just a little bit
harder and I would add to that too like
it's not always hardship too there's
other means of giving back to your
community it could be mentorship because
they're you know there are a lot of
single parents out there and uh says
professionals there may be people out
there that could use some advice it
could be professional advice it could be
you know personal advice there's there's
so many ways to have a positive impact
and I think so many people are isolated
even though they're so well connected
and social and I think the more we start
trying to find ways to interact with
people in our day-to-day that's not
holy digital I think the better off will
be yeah uh are there other products that
you see people building or other
companies that you're like wow they're
really onto something they're they're
absolutely killing it right now
like when I just ask that like what what
products or companies jump to mine as
like they seem to really have figured
something out
[Laughter]
people listen to me drinking a liquid
death I have a kid
that's a that's a first you understand
that this is the highest Roi thing that
they do yeah yeah for me they don't know
I'm an investor in the company and so
they send all these cans and like I just
like to be a completely honest the only
reason why I like drinking it other than
we're probably making money as people
see it is uh it's in a can it's not in a
bottle yes right and like every person
I've talked to in the health industry is
like stop drinking out of plastic
bottles okay cool this is not a plastic
bottle feel like I'm doing my like
Health kick uh but other than that what
else yeah I mean then the people who are
selling hats off to them I love them
I love the hydration packets so
protect is a veteran owned company and
they do these hydration packets also
um sleep packets
um they have like melatonin Gaba in them
um lmnt is another great one it's all
all those things are the things that
kind of have a day-to-day impact for me
so it's it's hard to I don't really fomo
on many Brands but I I really like what
those guys are doing just because I use
them on a day to day yeah yeah the um
the other thing is I've seen more and
more companies try to become media
businesses so they have the products and
then they go try to build the media
stuff and it feels like there's a lot of
people who are real I think maybe you
should do it the other way is like built
build the distribution and then figure
out the products chicken in the egg
right because there's there's risk when
you build a brand as a media company and
most brands rely on personalities early
on if they're going to do it that way
because there needs to be a
collaborative component to it typically
then there's exceptions to all rules but
there's a risk if your key Talent isn't
Founders owners in that
yeah I don't know that's a chicken or
red they're both problems to solve for
uh it's a cautionary tale for those who
do do the media thing and then they try
to throw a whole lot of money at it and
advertising because typically what
happens is they bring the wrong people
in to help them advertise and their
sample audiences are such a broad
demographic if I was to give any advice
to Media or cpg companies or anyone
that's looking to build and starting
either Media or product first you got to
know your demographic that is lesson
number one because if you're not focused
on that value proposition from day one
and you start bringing the wrong people
in you're going to go into a negative
um either engagement or algorithmic
spiral because
for us if we have an 18 to 45 U.S male
demographic and we start serving ads up
to a 65 year old Cambodian lady
she's going to bounce really fast or
she's not going to click through
whatever it is and all of these are
signals to the algorithm that she
doesn't care about the content and the
more people that don't care about the
content or the product the more of an
uphill battle it's going to be against
getting put into search and related and
that is another lesson that a lot of
people don't know it's like search
related discovery that is I would I
would argue most successful creators
that's going to be 50 to 70 percent of
their their Impressions yeah it's coming
just from the search yeah or related
what other platforms do you think people
should be posting content on like are
you long on YouTube shorts on tick tock
on reels on [__] something I've never
heard of before man it's a that's a big
one right because you have alphabet
which is publicly traded
and who knows what's going to happen
with Tick Tock but you also also have a
potential section 230 ruling coming up
January by January 30th and that has
potential implications for all curators
that is a that's a highly contested
uh
topic I guess you could say I have
strong opinions about it I think that
what do you think I I think that the
the platforms have been hiding behind
their section 230 privileges for too
long and there needs to be some changes
to it also if you do away with it that
takes away the search and related
component to or the the recommended
sorry
um
that has implications for the
recommended content which YouTube is
extremely good at recommending content
but I also have a chip on my shoulder
they don't like to recommend this stuff
that I make because it's not Advertiser
safe or Advertiser friendly I'm like
well uh screw you if an Advertiser spend
millions of dollars a year like Target
and they don't know how to set
exclusions for the type of content that
I create that is uh 100 legal
I'm sorry why should a whole industry of
content creators suffer that who have
built their entire business models off
of something you said was good five
years ago but now the tides have shifted
because it's not politically you know
acceptable do you think that when they
limit monetization it kills the virus
100 yeah and I can show you the
analytics because they claim that's not
true well they're full of [__] and I can
prove it like I I have I have the data
like fortunately for me I can say I have
a library of videos that go span 12 15
years and so some of my top performers
are from eight years ago and they have
20 30 million views and the cool thing
about analytics is you can see these
clear spikes and dips and I get emails
when they demonetize the video and there
is a spike the day of straight down
and then I appeal it it gets it gets
approved and we go through this whole
thing and it takes weeks sometimes
months and the views go from
um you know I don't know let's call it a
million views a month
to
a thousand views a month when it's
demonetized and then as soon as I get it
re-monetized it goes back up and you
could argue that something happened in
the world and maybe that changed that
but two of my videos they demonetized
them twice and the spikes are clear you
want to see something hilarious yeah
this is a video that has a 130 000 views
on it right you tell me where in the
video they demonetized it oh yeah no
super clear super clear like what where
where are we going here
right
you tell me where they demonetize that
video they claim that there's no impact
from demonetization but uh
I don't know what happened yeah and no
and they'll they'll give you some and I
look I totally understand it I know a
lot of people in YouTube and I feel
sorry that a lot of people get yelled at
and these emails and I
I understand the job's hard but it's
still frustrating as a businessman who's
who's not only YouTube's invested in me
but I've built my Brands and like like
the egos attached to that my I feel like
my soul's attached to it in some way
where it's like to lose that is it I
don't know I mean it makes me think if I
was them I would just be like yeah when
we demonetize the video or we limit the
monetization distribution goes down
because we don't make as much money off
the video you know we would all say like
or I'll pay it or make sense right like
got it okay well let's not get
demonetized I think it's the fact that
people all believe I mean when you see
that right and you're like literally
that exact moment is when they
demonetize the video and people see that
I think that they're like dude why are
you guys just just say that's what's
happening no I call [__] because
if it was just a monetization thing and
they were worried about their
advertisers screw it I have a coffee
company we pay a lot of influencers
for Impressions I will monetize every
single one of their channels we already
run the Shopify cart underneath our
YouTube videos how about you let us buy
all the ad inventory of all those people
you're demonetizing we'll run our ads on
it give us an advantageous Revenue share
split on it but they won't do it so
because it's on principle they don't
want the distribution
like they don't want that that content
to reach trending or whatever it is I'll
sell the ads I don't care if you're
worried about the hosting and the
streaming bandwidth [__] it I'll pay for
it does the Shopify cart underneath the
YouTube ad uh YouTube video work yeah of
course people buy yeah yeah I mean you
to be fair it takes work right and you
have to have product that people
actually care about a great a great
strategy is if you're incorporating any
type of product in a video you curate
that product through the carousel on the
bottom so it's easy for people to to
click through on it I see it right there
yeah yeah makes sense
um what what other Secrets or tips or
tricks do you have for people who uh are
trying to be on the internet
this I like literally people it's like
people come out of the woodwork I I
don't want to say who it is but uh I
recently had somebody who's an
accountant uh at an accounting firm I
don't use they reached out to me and
they were like hey I want to become like
a counting influencer person yeah and I
was like why would you want to do that
and they're like well because eventually
I could leave maybe I could make a
living just doing the content but also
then I could start my own accounting
firm and like they had this whole little
plan and I was like sure like why not
right guess what I do if I need an
accountant
like millions of other people around the
world they Google and if your content is
ranking up there like you have some
Advantage whether it's through ads
whether it's through building a business
whatever sure but I was like oh every
single industry somebody's gonna try to
do this okay so let's break this down
just off of your account and
um I love doing these kind of thought
exercises with people because it's
General it's no effort for me I have an
opinion again I'm a subject matter
Enthusiast take my advice with a grain
of salt algorithms change policies
change and you know what's working for
people today probably won't six months
from now but having said that for your
accountant and really anyone be
consistent with your value proposition
from day one you can experiment here and
there yes but don't fall into the Trap
of vanity metrics your ego wants you to
get those vanity metrics the likes the
comments the views and everything else
none of that [__] matters what matters
is the people coming to consume your
content care about it that is it like if
if you if if your goal is to get views
you might as well just be getting bikini
models or something like that it turned
into another form of Instagram right you
do a a provocative photo or something
like that or somebody being outrageous
in the thumbnail yeah you'll get views
but people only buy into that for so
long and if your value proposition isn't
consistent again let's go with your
account in here he's starting a channel
start creating accounting content don't
fall into the Trap of being Sensational
oh blah blah blah but be relevant in
your space hey
I don't know what accounting thing is
happening here in the world
um you know blackrock's doing this or
whatever it is and and break it down for
your viewers or hey here is 10 ways to
save money on your taxes do
collaborations he's going to have
Anthony over and we're going to talk
about my taxes today and we're going to
disclose to everybody how much you made
in 2022 or whatever it is right these
things these things that can help him
grow but he stays in his Lane and stays
consistently
um that that show would [__] pop if
somebody if there was an accountant that
created a show and they're I mean there
are a lot and there's no if you broke
down people's taxes yeah
especially if you start getting
celebrities
well and imagine again here's here's one
John Travolta used this tax trick to
avoid it's beautiful it's all right I
don't know anything about John Travolta
I just figured he'd be no it's great but
like and again I I geek out on this like
I'm giving this dude a million and one
suggestions I'd probably go on
socialblade or one of these websites and
and try to forecast what a Creator would
make based off of impressions
look and see if they had any AD deals
and then maybe forecast would a
production cost and like itemize and
deduct and all these other things you
could do like a a a high level forensic
for what it is like without actually
having access to that stuff and people
would it would probably grow and then he
could throw in these these really viable
healthy healthy like hacks for people
who don't have YouTube channels or
whatever it is uh but be consistent with
that and again like I was showing you
earlier with hot spots and everything he
could probably find a lot of videos and
ride on the coattails of it by
segmenting and commenting on that stuff
as a subject matter expert
the um the other thing I think a lot
about is like that's obviously like a
Services type business that eventually
could be content but the physical
products I'm shocked at how many
businesses that are in the physical
product game do not understand how
powerful the internet is like we've been
doing this [__] now for 20 years yeah
right like like the internet works right
well content works it does but they
still don't do it think about it this
way though
if you have a cpg company
and you have distribution
and it's
all you need you're not D to C
do you want the headache of scaling it
that way like I mean some people some
people get in Walmart or Target and
they're like I'm good
I've got that like I've I've I've I've
stood up this company and I've gone this
path before I don't really want to deal
with the headache of doing this thing I
mean to each their own but if you're if
you're a big brand I think that you're
missing an opportunity for the longevity
to not have some type of emotional
fabric woven in a media narrative to
kind of solidify that relationship with
your your consumer
when you think about
um
take somebody like Mr Beast right you
just uh they launched a new feastable uh
chocolate bar I think they're calling it
Deez Nuts yeah uh and I saw them tweet
out and say uh like whoever controls the
memes controls the internet
how like
how do you control the memes
Jimmy's like it's it's weird saying it
but Jimmy's a beast I think he is the
Beast uh he's his own animal like I'm
using all these puns but I'd use them
typically in that reference but
um yeah he's just a completely different
different machine like the dude is
yeah I did like it he's he's apples and
oranges in so many ways he's on such
another level now that I feel like
he could jump into any Market
as passionately as he is on everything
else and just crush it like he could as
long as he has the right teams to
maintain the QC and scale
I think whatever he does like I think
the average brand or entrepreneur isn't
going to have that yeah of course the
best but like how do you create or
control the memes in the way that
they're doing is it just because he's
got such a big audience he says
something and it's cool I think that's
it I mean he's to be fair what he says
is relevant what he says is funny but a
lot of other people do on the internet
too and it doesn't catch like that uh
some people some people it's like Prime
you know the uh drink Prime yeah you see
the numbers recently no
they claimed they did I think it was
Logan Paul my brother was tweeting about
it I think it's 250 million dollars in
Revenue last year and I think in January
they did like 40 million
in Revenue wow it's got to be a two
three billion dollar company but where
are they selling
here's the crazy part talk to anybody
with like a middle school child
especially a middle school boy they
can't find it it's sold out in all of
these but is it D to C or they have
distributions they have some DDC but
it's it's uh stuff in gas stations I've
sent him a gas stations interesting uh
but yeah they've like gone like the
traditional uh distribution path as well
yeah and so like I don't care what
you're you'd be selling [__] piece of
paper sell 250 million dollars worth a
piece of paper in a year you got a real
business yeah for sure for sure props to
him man props to him that is
right two wow two influencers wow uh who
like I would argue aren't just
influencers right obviously these guys
understand very very well they're really
smart businessmen they are lifestyle
brands of themselves yeah for sure yeah
yeah
wow I had no clue geez so to be on Pace
let's call it for somewhere between 400
and 500 million dollars in Revenue in
for a drink business you know for for
like a beverage business
Coca-Cola is going to call at some point
for sure and I just I I don't know you
want to guess let's just put on the
record what do you think they get bought
for
I mean
it depends I mean that like how old are
they
the business yeah not that old I mean
definitely less than five years old I
mean given the market and everything I
would say at least a five acts of annual
right of annual revenue yeah
I think that they have the potential
the potential
five billion or higher exit wow which is
basically all they got to do is if they
continue to grow
at kind of the rate that they're growing
yeah right you need another two to three
years if you can basically hold on and
not sell you're doing a million or a
billion dollars in Revenue dirty math
that's what like a 10x multiplier like
it'd be 10x from where they essentially
are right now yeah give or take yeah uh
but if they can hold out for another 12
to 24 months on top of that Jesus you
basically get to you know close to a
billion
I'm sweating right now I'm just I'm
thinking I'm thinking what is what is
that infrastructure look like behind the
scenes like how did they do this or did
they just did they just work in
agreement with somebody that could scale
it white label it I don't know all the
details but I think that somebody else
had the idea started like a beverage
business and then like brought them in I
I believe that's true somebody will
correct me if not
um but yeah like it once you get to any
type of scale I think people it's not
like hey we came up with this like crazy
idea we don't know what we're doing and
like we just happened to sell all this
stuff right yeah that's the hard thing
right because if for a brand to try to
find influencers to bring on
in kind of snowball it the risk on the
influencer is little to none in that
sense long as they know that they can
turn the knobs and ramp up production
and distribution if they if they follow
through on their promise that's a great
deal on their part because then they
don't they're just Sweat Equity they're
not necessarily having to even kick in
any money but on the flip side for for
influencers who try to build something
man it is a dice roll I am so fortunate
to have the partners I have like like
Evan just like he separationally he
stepped up to the plate operationally in
a way that I don't think many people
could have yeah like he he like it's
there's so many ways for a business to
fail especially if you're an influencer
trying to turn these dials on scaling a
business it's just it's easier to have
somebody who knows what they're doing
and I think that's what Jimmy does too I
think he he probably has people reach
out to him or his team his Network that
can follow through on execution and then
he gives the overall creative strategy
and marketing and everything else and
then they turn those Niles so
when um uh when somebody asks you what
do you do what do you say like are you
an entrepreneur are you an investor are
you a [__] influencer are you a
YouTuber it's hard are you an explosives
expert I I struggle with this and so we
just did this pevc uh event uh founder
event this week and I just tell people
I'm a subject matter Enthusiast I find
things that I'm really excited about and
I go hard in the paint I learn
everything that I can about it and I try
to be as best as I can in it it's hard
because again I make this joke
that whenever I was in Los Angeles
people perceived me as the gun-toting
redneck and when I was in Nashville I
was a gay love and liberal because
people inherently gravitate towards the
things they disagree with you on but I I
I
it's hard because I'm also a developer
I'm a marketer I'm like you know an
entrepreneur you know an investor all
these different things so I I'm the
worst on my social media because of that
it's easy for me to Define and refine a
brand or an influencer but it's hard for
me because I don't want to play that
game I don't want people to come to
Richard Ryan on social media and only
see slow motion guns or only see
business advice or only see this new
blockchain product and I probably burn a
lot of people whenever I talk about the
thing that they're not interested in
that consistent value proposition so I
read the room typically and I'm like hey
I'm I'm this guy I'm the chameleon yeah
all right last question for you is uh I
was talking to somebody recently and
they were like a great exercise is 10 20
years look out and think to yourself
like what does your Wikipedia page say
and that kind of keeps you like what's
your North Star for you what is your
Wikipedia page not say that it will say
a decade from now
will not say
well like what does it not have on there
now so you can't you get credit for
nothing you've done so far but like what
does it say a decade from now
well I mean regardless just happy dude
laughs
because for me so I've done this thought
exercise a lot in the past and I've
never never happy with who I am I am
miserably competitive I I look back on
myself six months let alone six years
ago and I hate the guy I was like I feel
like I grow so much in a short period of
time and that's good like you should
grow as a person you shouldn't stay
stagnant in your beliefs or your your
knowledge and everything else but I
aspire to hopefully make that person six
ten years from now happy that I am who I
am now because ultimately that's the
only person that's gonna matter because
I don't know what the future holds so I
try to live by you know my moral compass
for what it is and you know decisions
that I've made in my life I can look
back on and I can say hey look it may
not have been popular
but I did it the way I thought I should
and I didn't cave to either pure
political or whatever pressure that may
uh be against my belief system
it's pretty that's pretty [__] good
one yeah
yeah I was gonna say like like getting
uh to go public in New York and
[Laughter]
bro come on we just talked about YouTube
taking [__]
you can cut that I don't care
where can we send people to find you on
the internet yeah
um really yeah
anywhere anywhere it doesn't matter
Richard Ryan on all socials Twitter
Facebook
Instagram again I'm not consistent with
my value propositions on there so you
want to see some photos of me skydiving
doing stuff it's probably on Instagram
talking about the world and blockchain
and all that fun stuff it's on Twitter
and like I'm just all over the place
black riflecoffee.com and
um
full mag all these other different
channels
I love it thank you so much appreciate
it again in the future thank you sir
thanks for having me